you know what's up everybody guess what
we're back again more chess openings
more chess videos here on the chess calm
YouTube channel today we're here to
discuss the King's Indian which is our
first d4 covered opening at least as far
as the videos that I have covered here
the openings that I have covered that
you need to know for tournament chess
and it goes after Knight f6 c4 g6
night to c3 Bishop to g7 efore and
typically d6 we have reached the
mainline position of the King's Indian
and in order to continue here we're
going to focus on blacks ideas by
flipping the board and what I'd like to
point out is that the King's Indian is a
modern opening the the was not really
popular even played until you know the
late 40s early 50s and then into the 60s
and 70s and when the hyper modern era of
chess began because for a long time it
was thought that in order to give your
opponent this type of space advantage
and this type of control over the
critical squares in the center was
essentially dubious and in some cases
perhaps devastating and it wasn't until
guys like nimzowitsch came along and
then the players that used his ideas and
executed them further down the road
where he pointed out that you don't
necessarily need to have pieces
physically in the center in order to
have control over the game and the
king's engine is an opening that really
highlights that before we talk about
White's different approaches let's just
make a main line move Knight f3 so that
I can castle for black and talk to you
about what black would like to achieve
here essentially there are two main
goals two main forms of play but the
main one being to establish be 5 and the
second one being c5 not not as popular
anymore
the basic idea as I said is the black
doesn't have pieces physically in the
center here and why does have more
control in a literal sense however as
one example let's say that c5 occurs
after a move like Bishop e2 c5 and
because black maybe is threatening to
capture on d4 and then have holes on the
dark squares white plays the move d5 and
these types of positions were long
considered to be just better for the
first player being white but here we
have a pawn chain for black and if black
continue
to gain space on the queenside with
ideas such as Knight a6 relocating it to
c7 I move like rook ba Bishop d7 a6 if
necessary b5 we see that all of his
pieces coordinate around one type of
play which is designed to create open
space and counter play and eventually
use that open space in combination with
this sitting Bishop that's waiting in
the wings for potentially great play on
the Queen side so it's not to say that
that's the best plan for black or that
white necessarily is already worse in a
position like that but I wanted to point
out that once black achieves this type
of space with a pawn chain even though
he doesn't have pieces physically in the
center he does have a very clear plan
and this is how the forefathers the the
fathers of the hyper modern style of
chess started to play and understand
that you can have dynamic potential in
position with a bishop like this waiting
in the wings and even though you have
less space if you have a clear plan and
you coordinate your pieces with as such
like with the rook and Bishop eventually
working together to target squares like
b2 then you do have a good game now the
main line way to play is the line with E
5 which is black's main approach and
here the idea is also that after white
pushes the D pawn black intends to
release this Knight from his duties in
front of the F pawn and eventually get a
pawn storm attack on the Kings side with
the move f5 very similar to the plan
that black just developed when the
pollen chain was facing this direction
except in this case black is playing on
the Kings side now what black might do
here is is continue to close up the
position let me make a ridiculous move
for white here just to play it with a
move like f4 and all of a sudden we see
that again black has less space and
apparently quote-unquote cramped pieces
however all those pieces are headed
toward one direction of the board in the
direction of his pawn chain and this
type of plan would allow him to them
play moves like g5 perhaps g4 perhaps
bring more pieces over here with the
Queen and the rook and everybody getting
involved to the point where again he has
less space but if all the pieces are
attacking with one specific goal in one
direction of the board they can be
successful and this is the idea behind
the King's Indian to essentially give
both give white the center allow him to
establish these pawns
make one of these decisions either c5 or
e5 and then develop your attacking play
in one direction of the board depending
on which type of plan you chose I'm
going to point out that after the move
e5 is played white cannot really capture
on e5 to win this pawn as at the end of
a variation like this black can win his
pawn back and get a discovery on the
knight on e5 essentially heading toward
an equal endgame now to flip the board
back to White's perspective we can talk
about the fact that white has a few
different ways to approach the King's
indium the first and most popular way is
the main line that we started with
Knight f3 and after castles Bishop e2
normally we'll see e5 and usually the
move castles is played before I commit
after Knight to c6 D 597 black is ready
and prepared to retreat this Knight and
go for his plan and White has two main
ways to play with the move 991 being one
main line and the move 9b for
immediately preparing his own play in
the direction of his pawn structure on
the Queen side in order to gain
compensation for blacks counter play
again if you need more information on
this you can go to chess comm and search
chess games over the Internet and find
more information this move 9 before is
known as the bayonet attack in the
mainline Kings Indian the other main
line the White has in the Kings Indian
after d6 is the move f3 the same is
variation the same is variation has two
goals in mind one there's a potentially
there's potentially an idea that white
might even play Queen to d2 and council
long and quickly play the move g4
supported by f3 and eventually the move
h5 supported by G form we see these
pawns working together to hopefully open
the H file and eliminate the Bishop on
g7 for a checkmate attack now white may
not succeed with this planet very often
in main lines damages but it is an idea
and if black was to fiddle around and
perhaps not play the right plan maybe
even try for the same type of e5 plan as
he would in a mainline and some of these
cases that can really hurt black if
white simply reveals hey I'm not going
to counsel short and let you go for a
checkmate attack against me I'm going to
well time moves such as g4 h4 and h5 and
I'm in a pretty good position to develop
an attack here and instead of playing
the move e5 closing your Bishop you may
have wanted instead to play a move like
c5 to open the bishop to attack on the
Queen
90 c6 is a mainline way to play against
the Samish as well as the move c5 is as
this pawn sacrifice typically leads to
full compensation for black eventually
gaining access to the dark squares more
details of that are not really going to
be possible here but c5 is a mainline
move for black against the same as the
other ways white has to play one older
variation is the Arabic variation you
can look into that which has the
double-edged idea of putting more
pressure on the kingside however this
dark square bishop is usually an
important piece in order to defend
against blacks coming threats and if
black immediately tries for ideas such
as c5 and exposing the Queen side dark
squares this Bishop may regret having
left these critical squares once the
Queen and the bishop get rolling here on
putting pressure on points such as c3
the other idea is to play a g3 Kings
Indian which many cases can occur even
before the movie for with moves like
Knight f3 and g3 and in some cases even
the move order would g3 immediately here
white is essentially developing similar
type of peace play as black has just
done and we see the King side
essentially being symmetrical for both
black and white with both sides having
fianchetto dark square bishop here black
has a few different ways to play but
typically the classical plan of
something like c6 Knight B to d7 Queen
to c7 and eventually trying for a 5 as
well as potentially a 6 rook b8 and b5
are plans that players such as Bobby
Fischer employed when he played the
Kings in in his black as one particular
option so the Kingston is a very complex
opening that we tried to summarize for
you here in less than 10 minutes and
listening the main lines such as the
bayonet main line this Danish variation
as well as the Albert Bock and g3 lines
as white as White's options and also
showing you blacks main goal in this
type of hyper modern approach giving his
opponent the center in order to
establish a polishing and hopefully get
clear counter play despite the fact that
he has less space so rock and roll
Buttercup let's let's keep the videos
coming here in chest icon keep the
feedback coming please let us know if
you're appreciating this type of
coverage and whether you want a little
bit faster a little bit slower what do
you really want so let us know hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around on chess calm